the woman that loved to be to show
herself love to show her personality
like to look beautiful that it doesn't
have age from 20 88 years old every
woman that is a character in this man is
the same
many is the same manager is a classic
manner that sometime is very classic and
no because he has classic personality
because he has a classic job and some
time in Italy like all over the world
maybe more in America way in Italy one
job need a different kind of dress you
know that is deployed but when you go
home for Anna trees we can do let me go
with the Fred to play golf or maybe in
the evening if we go to the discotheque
or special dinner in this moment you see
the personality of one man who who is a
how you like to look if I make something
more special my biggest customer are an
item especially from the west coast so
they can because they want to look I
don't know they want to look special in
East part sometimes they're more afraid
because they are more the less free so
what do you think the main difference
between American and European man I tell
you that is a different that they're
American I have more courage
what's a piece of clothing for you that
you just be always comfortable one rigid
shirt that like a wear with your black
pants with geez maybe want some more
time why not let's bow tie or and I
greater share which both tie which color
maybe black a beautiful bed because the
belt sometimes it could be the jewelry
access or Excel Riya sexually fool I
don't like the back foot man ever a
beautiful new
sneakers that is important because
[ __ ]
today came before the day ever a gay
before the night